TOOOK!
ich muss mir kurz nochmal was aufschreiben auf dem... äh... auf dem Handy
Warum sagen wir eigentlich Handy in Deutschland? Niemand auf der Welt sagt Handy, warum sagen wir Handy?
Seh ich nicht
So
Die Batches sind da, ja. Das ist das letzte Mal. Guck mal, du hast den Diamantkeks. Ich hab noch mehr. Ich hab noch mehr, ich hab noch...
Ich hab noch einen Bronzekeks, einen Eisenkeks, einen Keks mit Hut und...
Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab einiges noch an Emotes
Wir sprechen Zahlen im Zehnersystem falsch aus
Machen wir das?
Warum?
Achso, 11 und 12. Da, das dachte ich mir. Das dachte ich mir.
Max, wie wärs damit?
Was ist das? Kann man das aufmachen?
Oh
Ah ja
Sieht ja fast aus wie Windows 11
So, irgendwie ist die Soundlautstärke nicht so ganz richtig
Der neueste Shit
Guck mal, der benutzt auch Sparkles
Garantiert, Windows 3, 11 oder so nicht gehabt
Was? Die Desktop-Animation in meiner Jubantu-VM
Sind relativ laggy und langsam, was kann man dagegen machen?
Du kannst was probieren, aber der Ubuntu-Desktop läuft in der VM
Okay, sagen wir mal
Aber nicht...
Nervt nicht
Windows 11, Alter
Das musste ich machen, ich musste Windows 11 verschlüsseln
Dass ich das neueste Windows 11-Update installieren durfte mit TPM 2 und dem ganzen Schiss, das in der VM gelaufen ist
Also was du machen kannst ist
Du kannst hier hingehen
In die Settings
Achso, gehts überhaupt um eine VM?
Ja, genau
Also du kannst in die Settings gehen, dann gehst du auf Display und sagst Accelerate 3D Graphics
Das kann was helfen, das kannst du ein bisschen schneller machen
Aber ich muss sagen, der Ubuntu-Desktop an sich ist jetzt nicht der geilste für eine VM
Also alles, was ich auf Grafikkarte fahre, eine Grafikkarte verlässt, ist meistens nicht so gut
Aber an sich gehts, ich hab auch eine Ubuntu-VM, um auf der Arbeit-Remote zu arbeiten
Geht eigentlich
Bist du gerade aufgewacht?
Ne, ich hab grad 3, achso
Ich wollt grad sagen, ich hab grad 3 Stunden, dann ist mir eingefallen
Ich hab offiziell nicht 3 Stunden
Lul
Aber ihr dürft den Kram hier eh bald spielen
So, wir sprechen, also hab ich schon gelesen, ja
Ja, es gibt Probleme
Es gibt wohl Probleme bei Amazon oder sowas
Ne, ich guck mir keine, einfach nur mal Just For Fun
Mal in die deutschen Trends reingucken, aber ich mach die nicht auf
Weil Trends gucken, Trends gucken ist wirklich hart am Limit
Habt ihr das Bild von dem Haus gesehen?
Das ist richtig, das ist richtig MonkaS das Haus, guckt euch das mal an
Spoder an der Wand, die gar keine echte Spoder ist
Oder auch das Gesicht in der Mitte oder so
Spodermann, Schussmanier, 11 Monate
Das ist richtig, ich weiß nicht, was mit denen abgeht, warum die so ein Haus haben
Aber das ist direkt rausgestochen, ich muss mal fotografieren, wenn ich da grad vorbeilauf
Also was haben wir für Trends? WhatsApp down, Telegram, Facebook down, Zuckerberg
Was Influencer
Was FWK21, was immer das sein soll
Muhammad4all, ist das der Hashtag von den Frankfurter Salafisten oder was ist hier los?
Ich klick keine Trends an
Auf Twitter, das ist immer PaynesChamp
Es gibt echt Schlimmeres, wenn Facebook down ist
Twitch könnte down sein oder Twitter oder so
Ich klick die Trends nicht an
DNS-Problem, es ist alles ein DNS-Problem
Warum tippst du in der Suchleiste ab und an rum?
Weil es hat keinen tieferen Sinn
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat, da gibt es sogar eine Erklärung dazu
Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn
Wieso heißt du eigentlich anders als in YouTube?
Tja, das liegt daran, weil ich den Account erstellt habe, lange bevor ich selbst vorhatte zu streamen
Ich streame seit, naja ist jetzt auch schon ein bisschen, aber den Account hier gibt es seit 7-8 Jahren oder so
Ist wirklich lang
Der Bot im Discord geht nicht oder was?
Doch, ich könnte den Usernamen ändern
Ich habe sogar einen Max-FPS-Account, also ich könnte den Usernamen ändern
Will ich aber gar nicht, ich finde es so eigentlich ganz gut, die Leute, die jetzt herkommen
Die kommen halt her, weil sie sich interessieren und sind doch keine nervigen Leute
Also ich habe festgestellt, es gibt im Internet ganz viel blöde Leute
Und auch nervige Leute, meistens dreht blöde Leute und nervige Leute zusammen ein
Das heißt, das beste, genau, Kacknoobs
Das beste, was man machen kann, ist eine gewisse Intelligenzschwelle einzubauen
Zum Beispiel, so dass diesen Transfer hinzubekommen von der Kerl heißt anders auf Twitch wie auf YouTube
Und das hält die meisten Leute, die mich nerven wollen von YouTube ab
Und gescheite Leute wie du finden das, damit kein Problem
5-Hat-Chat, genau
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat
Was ist das eigentlich?
Ah, irgendwie ist es ein altes Event
Genau
Leute, ich habe heute nichts vor, ganz ehrlich, ich habe nichts vor für den Stream, nichts Großartiges
Das Einzige, was wir machen können, ich habe noch ein paar Dinge, die ich im letzten China-Chinesen-Einkauf-Stream nicht los geworden bin
Die wollte ich...
Das stimmt nicht
Die wollte ich vielleicht noch...
Mal gucken, wo ich die bekomme
Und irgendwie habe ich mir gedacht, ich komme einfach nochmal an
Weil ich mir so dachte
So, den ganzen Tag ohne zu streamen, ist auch dumm
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich mache jetzt einfach an, wir schwätzen noch ein bisschen
Ja, quasi den ganzen Tag ohne Chat, das geht ja nicht
Was ist denn nun dein Messenger auf Joyce?
Tja, ich verwende ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Messenger Großartig
Die Messenger, die ich verwende, sind... also ich habe weder WhatsApp, noch Signal oder sonst was
Also ich habe mir mal einen Account gemacht, aber...
Ich verwende von der Arbeit Teams, das zählt ja nicht, es geht ja um private Sachen
Ich verwende eigentlich hauptsächlich Discord für alles Mögliche
Weil halt... weil, weil es praktisch ist
Aber ich verschicke da jetzt auch nicht super sensitive Sachen drüber oder so
Ansonsten, ich habe kein Tremer, ich habe kein Signal, ich habe kein Telegramm, ich habe kein WhatsApp, ich habe kein Skype mehr
Gar nichts, das einzige, was ich ab und zu verwende, ist...
iMessage eingebaut, mit Leuten, die auch ein iPhone haben
Aber das stelle ich eher zufällig fest, weil es grün wird, äh, ne, blau
ICQ, was sagst du zum Facebook Crash heute?
Meinst du Aktien oder meinst du Server?
Du meinst Server, ich weiß, dass du Server meinst
Äh, keine Stonks
Tja, was soll ich dazu sagen?
Ich dachte, AWS hat Probleme
Da sag ich doch, AWS hat Probleme
Guck mal, also gar MTV
Ja
Ah ne, auf AWS läuft alles normal
Ach, was auch immer, ist mir egal
Facebook nutzt noch jemand
Dachte, die haben die Server endlich abgeschaltet
Ey, es gibt noch genug Leute
Die Facebook verwenden
Weiß nicht, der Wendler und so
Die verwenden, glaub ich, auch noch Facebook
Kannst du dir mal die DAX-Studie
D-A-C-S
Studiengang der HSS
Kann mich keine Ahnung, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung
Ich weiß nicht mehr, für was das steht, aber ich bin echter Falsche, dazu was zu sagen
Wir wollten uns ja irgendwann mal diese Sache hier angucken, fällt mir grad auf
Stack Overflow Server 2021
Das ist jetzt schon eins, zwei Monate raus
Und wir haben es, glaub ich, schon nicht angeguckt
Weil ich mir gar nicht so sicher bin
Vielleicht haben wir uns das schon mal anguckt
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das noch mal an
Und dann fällt mir wieder ein, dass wir uns das vielleicht schon mal angeguckt haben
Es ist halt auch Instagram und WhatsApp kaputt
Ja, passt ja zu Facebook
Was macht der? Was macht der Zug wieder?
Facebook hat einfach aufgehört, einen Haufen IP-Adressen per BGP
Warum machen die sowas auch? Sind die blöd?
Oder vielleicht wollte auch irgendeine Netzwerk-Admin lustig sein, hat sich gedacht
Ich gebate den Zugabash mal
Die haben sich gedacht, hier, null, keck, wait
Am besten hätte er sich noch live streamen sollen dabei
Azubi am Furschen, ja
Wahrscheinlich
Nee, heute ist keiner sonderlich agil
Der Google-DNS ist schon am Klühen
Zum Glück gibt es den Google-DNS mehrfach auf der Welt
Und um mich jetzt noch mal komplett zu verwirren
Zumindest teilweise, wir wissen ja, der Chat hat high IQ
Die meisten im Chat sind nicht verwirrt
Den gibt es mehrfach mit der gleichen IP weltweit, den Google-DNS
Warte mal, 8888
Den gibt es nicht, die IP gibt es mehrfach auf der Welt
Was auch immer viele Leute verwirrt
Ja, ja, wir wissen, Chat, ich weiß, dass ihr schlau seid
Ihr müsst es mir immer beweisen, dass ihr schlau seid
Ihr seid Massive, Massive, Kopf
Ich weiß, ich weiß schon, Chat, ich weiß
Ihr seid, jetzt haben wir halt genug Subscribed
Das hat mittlerweile auf den Chat
Durchgeschlagen
Hier sind alle mindestens 150 IQ plus
Aber das verwirrt die Leute immer
Weil die haben ja alle mal gehört, ah, IP ist eindeutig
Ja, in der Regel ist das auch so
Es sei denn
Der Anbieter hat zu viel Geld
Zu viel Geld, die Mittel
Und was anderes als einen Vodafone-Anschluss
Mach das, mach das mal, mach das mal, Chano, ich mach heute eh nix
CloudFair versucht gerade 111 am Leben zu behalten
Was passiert denn eigentlich?
Haha, guck mal, echt, echt so
16 Uhr UTC, ja, was war denn das, 18 Uhr?
18 Uhr, 16 Uhr UTC, 18 Uhr vor zwei Stunden, oder?
Facebook Disappeared from the Internet
Was?
Das ist doch kein DDoS
Also wenn was per BGP nicht mehr announced wird, hat es ja mit DDoS nichts zu tun
Das muss irgendjemand sein mit Zugriff auf
Ja, sagen wir mal, zumindest ein paar Provider-Router
Sagen wir mal so, das nicht mehr announcen
Kann ja im Prinzip eigentlich nur von Facebook selbst ausgehen
Es könnte ja sein, dass mal wieder sich irgendein polnischer
Oder was war das letzte Mal, bulgarischer Provider aus Versehen
Die Netze von Facebook schnappt
Wobei es nicht Facebook war, sondern
Was war das letzte Mal, weil da war irgendwas
Dass irgendein Netz von, genau
Irgendein Provider hat sich das Netz von der Telekom gekrallt
Die IPs, wo die IPs drin sind, die DSL-Kunden bei der Einwahl kriegen
Dann gings, gab es Probleme
Oder war das, oder war das umgedreht
Ach, ich weiß es nicht mal
Ja, Chet, seid ihr Team 1111
Oder seid ihr Team 8888
Was DNS angeht
So viele Einser hier
Also ich bin Team 8888
Aber manchmal bin ich auch Team 1111
Jetzt kommt der erste mit der IPv6-Adresse um dir
Zockst du auch im Stream
Ja
Ich glaube, also mein Battlefield
Also wir spielen auf jeden Fall, wenn die Battlefield Beta da ist
Spiel mir ein bisschen im Stream
Ich kling's müde, ja, ja, es war auch relativ anstrengend heute
Obwohl ich heute nicht arbeiten musste, morgen muss ich wieder arbeiten
Ich hab Kopfweh
Und heute war echt anstrengend
Ich hab heute Vormittag Video gemacht zu Windows
Zwischendurch war ich mal eine Stunde, hab mich ein bisschen bewegt
Dann hatte ich Event heute Abend
Aber es war heute echt anstrengend
Ja, bloß zwei Cry, nee, ich hab seit gestern nicht mal gespielt
Hast du schon was gefuttert? Ja, hab ich
Battlefield Beta soll rund 20 GB groß sein, doch keine zwei Tage warten
So, so soll sie das
Die Beta kommt, äh, morgen kannst du glaube ich preloaden
Und
Dann kannst du ab übermorgen spielen
Und ich glaube, Open für alle ist die ab 8.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz falsch lege
Plants vs. Zombies haben wir lustigerweise auch mal im Stream gespielt, ja
Und ich glaube, wir haben auch schon mal ein bisschen gespielt
Bin mal gespannt, was ihr zum Game sagt
Tja, mal gucken, was Facebook macht
Ich meine, ich hätte keine Probleme mit, wenn Facebook down bleibt
Das juckt mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht
Ob, also es gibt wirklich kaum eine Seite, die mich so wenig tangiert, wie ob Facebook jetzt up oder down ist
Ist mir, ist mir egal, um nicht zu sagen, scheiß egal
Ich meine, ich bin zwar im Alter, wo man jetzt sagen würde, ja, ich bin Facebook Benutzer
Aber bin ich nicht
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich bin ich auch ein bisschen zu jung
Also, ab wann, also, naja gut, das stimmt nicht, also
Sagen wir mal so, meine Generation und älter benutzt Facebook
Die Jungen benutzen ja alle kein Facebook mehr, die Jungen haben entweder Instagram
Zwischenzeitig hatten die Leute mal Snapchat, aber Snapchat ist glaube ich schon nicht mehr
Die allerneueste Generation, sondern die davor
Und ansonsten heute, heute sind die Leute auf TikTok
Ich meine Snapchat
Snapchat, muss ich mal sagen, ich habe nie den Sinn von Snapchat verstanden
Ich meine, ich weiß warum es so erfolgreich ist, Snapchat ist erfolgreich, weil sie gesagt haben
Hey, wenn du irgendwelche Dickpicks verschickst, du kannst da sicherstellen, dass die wieder gelöscht wird
Was schwachsinnig ist
Also Snapchat, Snapchat ist nur erfolgreich geworden wegen irgendwelchen Nacktbildern
Reddit ist Pog, ja, wobei Reddit zähle ich jetzt nicht so sehr unbedingt zu Social Media dabei
Reddit ist für Mission 4, also wenn Reddit, ok sagen wir so, Leute
Ist Reddit Social Media?
Und wenn ja, dann ist GitHub aber auch Social Media
Dann ist GitHub, dann ist GitHub das Programmier Social Media
Und Stack Overflow, ja, genau
Jira auch, ne, das ist ja meistens closed
Moin Max, ich bin jetzt
Sekunde, ich muss warten, bis der Chat stehen bleibt, dass ich das lesen kann
Moin Max, bin jetzt in der 12. Klasse
Übrigens Leute, wer heute zum ersten Mal da ist
Ich weiß nicht, ist jemand zum ersten Mal da
Und heute, ihr dürft heute nichts Großartiges vom Stream erwarten, das sage ich euch gleich
Also, ich bin einfach nur nochmal on gekommen, um on zu kommen
Ich, ja, ganz klar Chat, das sehe ich schon
Schokode?
Wie schreibt man, wie sagt man das?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht, aber
Ich kann es mal vorlesen, also
Moin Max, bin jetzt in der 12. Klasse
Und gucke mir verschiedene Berufe an
Ah, so wie der Stecker
Plus ohne, also nicht wie der Schuh
Ne, wie der Schuh, wie der Schuh zum Anzeln, nicht wie der Stecker
Okay, also
12. Klasse und
Make alright, danke schön
So, 12. Klasse, gucke mir verschiedene Berufe an
Hab Interesse an DevOps Engineer
Hab aber in der Schule Informatik abgehört, das macht nichts
Weil das bei mir auf der Schule kacke ist
Und man nur Java-Kram benutzt
Ja
Kann ich mir auch einfach nebenbei ein bisschen was beibringen?
Kenne auch Leute
Zu bemeiden, für sowas hätte ich Physik
Was, Quatsch, Physik hat überhaupt nichts zu tun
Aber nein, nein, nein, das ist Schwachsinn, das ist Physik
Also, äh
Falls du bald später
Was in Richtung DevOps machen musst, musst du entweder
Ein, ein
Studium machen oder eine Ausbildung
Als, sagen wir, fachinformatische Anwendungsentwicklung
Fachinformatische Systemintegration oder eins von den Leuten
Du brauchst, du brauchst in irgendeiner Art und Weise eine Ausbildung
Sei es jetzt ein Studium oder sei es halt eine Ausbildung
Du musst irgendwas lernen dafür vorher
Und dann
Je nachdem
Ob deine Fähigkeiten dazu passen
Und ob das Unternehmen, wo du bist, was sucht
Oder ob du jetzt den Stellanzeigen findest
Dann kannst du dich da drauf bewerben
Wichtig ist, dass man da ein bisschen Überblick
Über aber beide Seiten hat
Ja, also man muss sich auskennen, was Softwareentwicklung angeht
Man muss sich aber auch auskennen
Wie betreibt man Software
Ich hab halt das Glück gehabt, deswegen bin ich da auch reingerutscht
Ich hab halt das Glück gehabt, ich hab bei einem Provider
Meine Ausbildung gemacht
Das heißt, ich hab relativ viel Linux gelernt
Relativ viel Netzwerkgeschichten gelernt
Und ich hab das auch eine ganze Weile gemacht
Deswegen
Wurste ich ja hier im Stream manchmal
Irgendwelche komischen Bash-Dinger hin
Wo sich alle fragen, was macht das jetzt
Das hab ich in der Ausbildung zum
Kurzen Teil mir damals angeeignet
Da war sehr viel Turnschuhe-Administration auch mit am Start
War ich im Rechenzentrum und sonst was
Das heißt, ich hab mich, kenn mich
Seit meiner Ausbildung
Und ein paar Jahre danach, wo ich da gearbeitet hab
Kenn ich mich halt ganz gut aus
Was die Systemseite anbelangt
Ich hab mich aber schon immer
Fürs Programmieren interessiert und hab auch schon
Seit Jahren immer wieder kleine Sachen gemacht
Hauptsächlich privat
Aber dann jetzt
Über die letzten Jahre auch immer mehr auf der Arbeit
Angefangen von Tools
Zu Tests, zu allen möglichen Sachen
Und
So ging das nach und nach
In diese Richtung
Also man braucht da schon ein bisschen
Überblick in alle Richtungen
Also quasi
Full Stack
Wie war das? Full Stack
Bis Sack DevOps
Nein, Quatsch, man muss es nicht übertreiben
Aber einfach so
Jetzt nach der Schule zu sagen
Ich geh jetzt in den DevOps-Bereich, stell dich mir schwierig vor
Weil du hast ja eigentlich noch vor nichts so richtig
Eine Ahnung
Die Schulausbildung ist ja da
Also das bisschen, was man an der Schule an
Sachen lernt, was Programmieren und so angeht
Kannst du vergessen
Am schlimmsten fand ich es immer
Wenn wir irgendwelche Azubis bekommen haben
Und ich hab die dann gefragt
Ja erzähl mal so, was hast du so getrieben
Dann erzählen die und dann
Tragt man dann auch nach einer Zeit so
Und was hast du schonmal mit Linux gemacht
Und was hast du schonmal damit gemacht
Was hast du schonmal so und damit getrieben
Und am schlimmsten fand ich es dann immer
Wenn man Leute hat, die zu allem gesagt haben
Ja super, super toll hab ich schon gemacht
Ja ja kenn ich mich gut aus
Du hast gesagt, ah ok
Kennst dich gut aus, dann
Hab ich hier was
Und dann hast du festgestellt, wenn du hast was machen lassen
Ein absolut kein Plan
Also
Bisschen
Man soll sich da nicht zu sehr überschätzen
Ja, aber wenn du was in der Richtung machen willst
Dann wäre eigentlich, jetzt haben wir eine Ausbildung
Als Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration
Ausbildungsentwicklung nicht schlecht
Seien, du willst was studieren, kannst du natürlich auch machen
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein
Entspannendes Gebiet
Weil es eben ziemlich breit
Gefächert ist
Dann Slack auch Social Media
Dann ist Teams auch Social Media
Irgendwo ja schon
Was ist Discord?
Eigentlich auch Social Media
Oh nein, nein, nein
Hör mal auf, bloß damit fangen wir jetzt
Nein, nein, nein, damit fangen wir nicht an
Null
Jetzt, der Chebated
Was ist, was ist mit dem
Der Chat heute
Was ist hier los?
Aber so
Aber so offensichtlicher Chebat
Rasendrescher, danke für den Sub
Ach, ich dachte er hat sich verschrieben
Yavacara gibt's wirklich
Ich dachte er wollte Yavacram schreiben
Und hat sich verschrieben
Yavacara, das gibt's wirklich
Ah
Das ist so was wie
Wie dieser Robot, der sich dann bewegt
Und Dinge
Okay, solche Sachen gibt es ja
Für alle nur in den eigentlichen Sprachen
Ja, ja, das ist
In dem Fall ist es Marienkäfer
Das gibt's auch mit einem Roboter, der rumläuft
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht
Gar nicht doof
Also ich finde es gar nicht schlecht damit anzufangen
Da lernt man schon ein bisschen die Basics
Was man dabei halt gar nicht lernt ist
Wie man irgendwie ein Programm strukturiert
Alles außer
If schleifen und 2-3
Funktionen verwendet
Kommt drauf an was man macht
Ich hab letztes gelesen, dass
An der Schule
Dass die Schulen
In Deutschland jetzt informiert
In Nordrhein-Westfalen glaube ich
Oder was war heise
Schulen
Dass die
Irgendwie Informatik als
Ja
Die Jungsfraktion wollen
Schulfach Informatik aufwändern
Frage ich mich wer soll das denn machen
Wie If schleife
Wollt ihr mir sagen es gibt keine If schleife
Ich hab keine Ahnung Leute
If schleife, natürlich gibt es eine If schleife
Eine If schleife
Besteht
Aus nem Label
Nem If und nem Go to
Also Leute jetzt, wollt ihr mir hier erzählen
Was es gibt oder nicht gibt
Ja ich natürlich
Jetzt mal ernsthaft
Nein es gibt keine If schleife
Aber wenn man mal genauer drüber nachdenkt
Gibt es doch ne If schleife
Ein If ist ne Anweisung
Das ist schon richtig was der Chat sagt
Aber man kann mit Go to und ne Anweisung
Eine If Anweisung durchaus auch ne Schleife bauen
Da sieht man
Es ist alles
Nur ne Frage wie sehr man drüber nachdenkt
Irgendwas findet man immer
Ich frag mich wer das hier unterrichten soll
Und außerdem
Jetzt kommen gleich die Assembler Leute
Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem
Man braucht noch nicht mal ne If
Wobei man halt mal sagen muss
Naja
Ne If
Also
Lässt sich ziemlich eins zu eins
In Assembler übersetzen
Das ist übrigens auch eins der wenigen Sachen
Die ich mal in Assembler gemacht hab
Hab ich das nicht sogar mal im Stream gemacht
Haben wir nicht mal
Wir haben im Stream ESP 32
Assembler Krams Zeug gemacht
Das war eklig
So
Will man sagen
Ja nice
Cool dass du den Weg hier gefunden hast
Der Provider
Hallo
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz
Das neue Windows von Microsoft
Ist da
Und euer Provider
Sackt
Ne das würde er so nicht sagen
Richtig genau so siehts aus
Ich komm mit dem Chat nicht hinterher
Aber das ist nicht schlimm
Weil ich hab heute eh nichts großartiges vor
Huge Bits
5 Billionen Euro
Ist das schon Windows 11
Nope, aber wenn du Windows 11 haben willst
Ich hab hier Windows 11 am Start
Oh ne das ist ja
Übrigens wenn sich jemand fragt
Ich zeig euch das mal kurz
Wenn sich jemand fragt wie kriegt man
Windows 11 in einer VM zum laufen
Was ihr machen müsst ist folgendes
Pass mal auf
Ihr müsst in die Options gehen
Und ihr müsst sagen
Encryption an
Und vergibt irgendwie ein komisches Passwort dafür
Weil geht nicht anders
Müsst ihr machen
So danach geht ihr in advanced
Sagt ihr Enable Secure Boot
Und dann geht ihr hier auf add
Und sagt Trusted Platform Module
Und wenn ihr das gemacht habt
Dann könnt ihr Windows 11 starten
In der neuesten Version und es meckert nicht
Dass ihr kein TPM habt
Ja
Wo siehts aus
Ja das ist immer
So ein Ding
Was habt ihr für gute informatische
Schulausbildung
Wir Kliemor
Achja Klimper noch in Excel
Auch Windows XP Roar
Also wir haben in der Schule
Wir hatten auch Informatik in der Schule
Nur mit dem Unterschied
Dass das bei uns absolut null
Mit Informatik zu tun hat
Was wir gemacht haben in der Schule ist
Wir hatten einen Lehrer der konnte nichts in der Richtung
Aber der konnte
Word bedienen
Und dann haben wir Word gemacht
In Informatik
Und du musstest eins glaube ich
Ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt
Du musstest die Seite im Prinzip immer einfach nur im Hintergrund
Lila machen
Und dann hast du eine 1 gekriegt
Oh Lila Lila Lila
Und dann hat er sich mega gefreut
Und dann hast du eine 1 gekriegt
Richtig hängen geblieben
Richtig bescheuert
Ja es war so
Genauso bescheuert
Wie sich das jetzt angehört
Dann war das halt
PowerPoint haben wir auch gemacht
Ich weiß noch ich hab damals
Eine PowerPoint Präsentation gemacht
Aus der Schule
Die haben wir auch Lila Vorlage gemacht
Lila Vorlage
Also Lila alles gefärbt
Und im Hintergrund
Haben wir auf der einen Seite
Irgendein Lied von Metallica reingemacht
Damals
Einfach so random
Ich weiß gar nicht warum
Und dann ist rausgekommen
Das fand der Lehrer auch noch übelst geil
Wie gesagt
Aber
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich also bei mir ist das jetzt
Das haben wir legen gesagt
Wie lange ist denn das her
25 Jahre oder so
Ich kann durchaus sagen viertel Jahrhundert
Alter
Naja
Bei mir auf der Schule gibt es auch diese
Mint Zertifikat
Die beworben werden als Master für
Ich hab keine Ahnung was das ist
Nach mir gar nichts
Also so super wichtig können die Dinger nicht sein
Pinterest
Gibt es das doch
Twitch klar ist Twitch Social Media
Wollte ich sagen das wäre nicht Social hier
Das kommt drauf an wo du dir das anguckst
Ich bin viel zu weit hinten dran
Das Krümel Dankeschön für die Subs Leute
Auch wenn es heute echt ein bisschen langweilig ist
Für alle aber
Muss auch mal sein
Ja vor allem den
Heute hier
Kannst du mit meinem Discord Bot helfen
Äh nicht wirklich
Nee da hab ich keine großartige Ahnung von
Warum ich glaub das findet er lustig
Ey ich mein
Wenn man so eine eigene Eigenheit
Hat was Begrüßung und Ansprache
Ich mein bei mir kann man sich ja auch teilweise
Darüber lustig machen
Ich würde gerne mal bei
Semper Video ein Video hochladen
Wo ich fake Semper Video zu sein
Das wäre doch
Das wäre doch was
Hallo in diesem Video noch ganz kurz
Da müsste ich üben
Mein Bruder hat
By the way in der fünften Informatik
Und haben über Cybermobbing
Geredet
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht das in Informatik
Zu machen finde ich
Ich mein es passt thematisch
Also Social Media Internet
Stellskram passt ja noch am ehesten
Da rein und vielleicht hat man dann
Dadurch dass es der Lehrer macht
Den Informatik auch einen der technisch
In irgendeiner Art und Weise kompetent ist
Nein nein Quatsch wir haben keine
Makros gemacht in Word null
Ich glaube es geht los das war
Dass es das wusste der Lehrer wahrscheinlich mal dass die Funktion überhaupt gibt
PowerPoint in Word
Yup wir auch
Facebook aus von dem Packet Tracer nachmachen
Das könnten wir tatsächlich machen
Das ist eine gute Idee das schreiben wir mal auf
Das könnte man tatsächlich nachstellen
Und mal auf YouTube mal ganz kurz zeigen
Wobei ich ja im Packet Tracer nachmachen
Den Telekom Ausfall anschaulicher fand
Ja ja ist ja gut chat
Meine Güte ey
Was ist das eigentlich für
Wenn man schon die Sachen
Copypaste
Dann könnte man wenigstens
Was ist das eigentlich für
Wenn man schon die Sachen
Copypaste dann könnte man wenigstens
Story richtig schreiben
Oder ist das Teil
Oder ist das Teil der Copypasta
Dass es Stroy heißen muss
Stroy
Wir hatten damals auch nur Office Programme
Und 10 Fingertippen gelernt
Das kann ich mal so schlecht wenn man das
In der Schule lernt
Ich kann das bis heute nicht richtig
Echt
Ja gut
Die Leute haben dann wahrscheinlich gleich Angst
So nach dem Motto
Sie wurden gehackt oder so
Keine Ahnung
Ach es ist echt
Wahnsinn wisst ihr also ich dachte ja
Eigentlich so sagen wir mal
Als ich in dem Alter war
Wo man in der Schule war
Und wo keiner was gecheckt hat
Da dachte ich mir damals
Boah das ist bestimmt richtig cool
So in den nächsten 1-2 Generationen
Wenn dann die Lehrer
Und so auch alle Ahnung von der Technik haben
Ich mein damals musstest du teilweise
Dem Lehrer schon den Videorekorder
Noch anmachen weil die zu dumm waren
Das einzuschalten bzw.
Richtig umzuschalten
Du hattest natürlich dann auch immer
So die richtigen Schleimer
Am Start die überall hingerannt sind
Ja ja ich komm mit ihnen hoch und hol auch noch
Den Videowagen alles gar kein Problem
Hätten sie erwegs das
Noch schön langsam gemacht das im Viertelstunde
Vorweg ist
So und ich dachte mir so
Wie cool das ist wenn so die Generation danach
Dann richtig Ahnung hat weil ich dachte mir so
Ja guck quasi die Leute wie ich
Die da jetzt sitzen sich das E-Land angucken müssen
Die sind dann halt mal später selbst
An dieser Position aber ich glaube
Keiner mit irgendwie technischem Verständnis
Oder kaum einer ist Lehrer geworden
Also es gibt sicherlich mehr
Fähige Informatiklehrer als früher keine Frage
Früher war ja quasi so einer von 100
Heute sind es wahrscheinlich 2 von 100
Also immerhin schon 100% mehr
Aber es ist immer noch
Es erstaunt mich
E immer noch im Jahr
2021 wie
Unfähig viele Leute sind
Was Technik angeht
Und witzigerweise gerade
Auch jüngere Leute wo ich eigentlich
Immer davon ausgegangen bin
So nach dem Motto die sind damit
Aufgewachsen die haben das eigentlich im Blut
Das ist eigentlich überhaupt gar kein
Problem mehr aber sogar die
Struggeln übelstrum
Also
Ich verstehe nicht
Die Musik muss jetzt nicht sein
Das klicke ich nicht an
Das ich weiß nicht was es ist
Aber das klicke ich nicht an
Ja ich komme nicht so weit
Bin ich nicht so schnell
Ist bloat
Diese Zertifikate ja die sind bestimmt bloat
Ja das weiß ich aber ich habe keine Ahnung was es für Zertifikate sind die es da gibt
Hast du keine Augenprobleme
Wenn du 8 Stunden am PC
Auf der Arbeit bist also
Ich versuche keine 8 Stunden am PC zu sitzen
Am Stück
So weder auf der Arbeit noch bei mir daheim
Aber ne ich habe keine Augenprobleme
Ich sehe ziemlich gut
Soll ich jetzt mal eine Sache wo ich
Mit irgendwelchen so
Körperlichen Sachen mal angeben kann
Ich habe 150%
Sehkraft
Ich habe kein passendes Bild dafür
Weird Flex
Das ist kein Witz ich habe wirklich 150%
Sehkraft
Das Teleskop
Nee ganz so schlimm ist es nicht
Aber man kann sich das
Nicht mit Brille nicht mit Brille ohne Brille
Man kann sich das ungefähr so vorstellen
Wenn man einen Sehtest macht also daher weiß ich das auch
Also ich habe einen Sehtest
Ich habe einen Sehtest gemacht
Da musste ja dann
Warte mal habe ich ein Ding reingeguckt
Nee ich glaube
Ich habe einfach über Entfernung
Genau ich habe einfach über Entfernung geguckt
Was man sieht
Und dann irgendwann
Meinte ja super alles okay
Und jetzt noch mal so just for fun
Und dann hat er mich rumgedreht
Hat mich in den Spiegel gucken lassen also hat quasi so die
Doppelte Entfernung gemacht nochmal zusätzlich
Und ich konnte es immer noch lesen
Auch wenn es schwierig war
Du siehst den Ausgabe
Du hast von was gehört
Sagt mir nichts
Ausrufezeichen eins im Chat wir haben das
Ich habe das schon oft genug erklärt
Das ist so ein Tick von mir das hat keinen tieferen Sinn
Das ist genauso wie das
Ich hier oben das ich hierzu
Dinger copypaste
Ja das fände ich auch nicht schlecht
Was das Packet Tracer
Das ist so ein Netzwerk Simulationsprogramm
Wo man dann genau gucken kann
Was wie wo verschickt wird
Ja ich weiß auch nicht
Aber wahrscheinlich findest du gute Informatik Lehrer
Genau da wo du alle anderen guten Lehrer
Auffindest
Das sind auf der einen Seite Leute die sich mit dem
Bereich ganz gut auskennen
Also ein guter Informatik Lehrer
Muss nicht wirklich herausragend
Gut Informatik sein
Da muss ein guter Lehrer sein
Und sich irgendwie auch ein bisschen dazu berufen fühlen
Und sich da ganz gut auskennen
Was ist das
Ich finde bist du ein Regex
Geht so
Ich weiß es gibt Regex Challenges
Das kann man mit Sicherheit abkacken
Kennt ihr das Regex Kreuzwort Rätsel
Also wenn mal
Einer wirklich
Sein Hirn ein bisschen
Abfacken will
Dann kann er das Regex Kreuzwort Rätsel machen
Also das funktioniert dann folgendermaßen
Du musst halt gucken
Was kannst du hier reinschreiben wo alles drauf matcht
Also hier unten
Hier unten
Kann es entweder Well oder Ball
Oder Ir sein
So und jetzt muss man gucken
Was davon
Was davon würde auch hier oben
Drauf matchen
Nix
Bin ich jetzt zu dumm
Hä
Okay dann habe ich nicht verstanden wie es funktioniert
Also ich meine das hier
Das hier ergibt ja noch irgendwie Sinn
Das ist eine
Gruppe an Zeichen
B
Und dann noch ein zusätzliches Zeichen
Aber da ist auch kein L drin
Da ist kein E drin
Da ist kein A drin
Hier ist kein F drin
Hier ist kein R
R ist drin
Aber kein E und
A
Hä
Okay dann habe ich nicht verstanden wie es funktioniert
Aber wir müssen es uns jetzt auch nicht übertreiben
Hä
Ach da oder können da
Moment da können immer nur
Jetzt verstehe ich es
Da können immer nur einzelne Buchstaben rauskommen
Oder
Dann verstehen habe ich es nicht genau gecheckt
Ist auch egal
Hä
Aber so die meisten Rekord Sachen
Check ich schon
Was ist eigentlich wenn einer nur 9
Oder weniger Finger hat
Fällt er dann durch beim 10 Fingerschreiben
Oder bekommt er automatisch ein 1
Der muss für den 10. Finger mit 9 Fingern mitschreiben
Ist doch klar
Beim 10 Fingerschreiben geht es ja eigentlich
Wenn man ehrlich ist
Es ist kein Problem ob man 10 Finger schreibt
Sondern dass man schreiben kann
Ohne auf die Tastatur zu gucken
Und dass man
Allweg schnell ist
Dass man schnell ist ohne auf die Tastatur zu gucken
Ja dann so kann man das auch machen
So kann man das auch machen
Wir nutzen immer noch
Echt ernsthaft gibt es noch
Schuhe mit Offerhead Projektoren
Das ist alles so letztes Jahr
Tausend mann
Gibt es Schuhe ohne Offerhead Projektoren
Ja das müsste man wirklich schreiben
Ich meine ein Offerhead Projektor
Das ist ja an sich nicht schlecht
In dem Sinn
Das ist jetzt nicht so
Als wäre das was total
Wo man sagen muss ja das ist so kacke
An sich sind Offerhead Projekte
Und so eine Tafel durchaus ok
Aber die Sache ist halt nie
Ich glaube die nehmen das nicht einfach weil es eine einfache Möglichkeit ist
Da interaktiv so ein bisschen was zu zeigen
Sondern weil es nichts anderes gibt
Von der Technik her
Das ist glaube ich eine
Eigenschaft von Französischlehrern
Lehrerinnen
Muss man heutzutage sagen
Dass sie keinen Plan haben
Warum sollte man Lehrer werden
Frag mal den Sebaro
Frag ich mich auch
Der Sebaro
Der Sebaro müsste das wissen
Der Sebaro will ja Lehrer werden
Wo ist der Cute Mod eigentlich
Der Ober Cute Mod
Der war schon lange nicht mal hier
Chainlord will auch Lehrer werden
Glaub ich dir sofort
Ich kann mir den Chainlord
Als Lehrer richtig gut vorstellen
Da fragt ihn dann irgendjemand
In der Klasse
Chainlord könnten sie nochmal erklären
Wie das war was sie da letzte Stunde gezeigt haben
Und der Chainlord sagt dann einfach
Recycle
Recycle Story
So warum wundert dich
Dass Menschen technisch unfähig sind
Weil ich gedacht habe wenn Leute damit aufwachsen
Dann wird das besser
Naja es geht ja nicht so sehr darum
Dass man versteht wie die Sachen
Intern funktionieren
Aber zum Beispiel
Dass man weniger auf Scams
Rein fällt
Warum glauben die Leute
Wirklich
Dass wenn sie ihren Schwanz fotografieren
Und per Snapchat verschicken
Dass das Foto niemand sonst sehen kann
Und sich das automatisch wieder löscht
Warum glauben das die Leute
Wie bescheuert kann man eigentlich sein
Warum glauben die das
Und gerade jemand der mit Technik aufgewachsen ist
Von dem hätte ich jetzt eigentlich erwartet
Dass man sowas durchschaut
Ist halt echt so
Was läuft hier nichts
Ich habe einfach nur den Stream angemacht
Heute um ein bisschen zu schwätzen
Wir machen heute nichts großartiges
Könnte ich überhaupt nur mit Informatik
Lehrer werden
Keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt
Das ist doch schonmal
Ein Anfang
Was stimmt
Mein Sitz nach Bar
War zu unfähig um die Dokumente zu drücken
Weil man dafür zuerst in die VPN der Schule rein musste
Ja
Je nachdem wie das gemacht ist
Ich gehe mal davon aus es ist nicht sonderlich schwierig
Weil die Lehrer können es auch bedienen
Halbes Teleskop
Ich finde diesen Spruch so geil
Das muss ich bemerken
Wenn mal einer
Wenn mal einer wieder irgendwas sieht
Was ich nicht sehe sage ich auch
Das ist ein Teleskop
So weg ex
Oh nee nee ich muss es jetzt überspringen
Mein Gott schon so spät
Ja in einer Stunde
Was ist in einer Stunde chat
Geh
Also ich finde es auch nicht schlecht
Ich kann das bis heute nicht richtig
Also ich schreibe
Also ich würde sagen
Ich schreibe so mit
Hallo das hier ist mein Stream
So das habe ich jetzt
Geschrieben ohne hin zu gucken
Mit ich würde sagen
Fünf
Fingern
Ja ich glaube fünf Finger
Das ist auch nicht so richtig
Richtiger Painschamp
Bei der IHK Abschlussprüfung
Haben sie mir damals noch gesagt
Dass die IHK einen
Overheadprojektor stellt für die Abschlusspräsentation
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht
Ja super
Das finde ich cool so was
Also quasi Tafeln
Die keine richtigen Tafeln mehr sind
Ja da scheitert es nicht
Das finde ich cool
Das finde ich cool so was
Also quasi Tafeln
Die keine richtigen Tafeln mehr sind
Ja da scheitert es dann halt daran
An den Lehrer
An sich ist das nämlich
Eine wirklich coole Sache
Wenn man da was halbwegs modernes hat
Da kann man nämlich
Da müssen sich die Leute auch nicht
Kennt ihr das in der Schule
Das muss ich jetzt mal sagen
Es gab mehrere Fraktionen
Es gab die
Die haben alles
Im kleinsten Detail
Abgeschrieben was der Lehrer an die Tafel
Geschrieben hat
So nach dem Motto
Als lernen sie das dadurch
Die hatten quasi
Gar keine Zeit
Zu zuhören und zu gucken
Die haben einfach nur alles
Möglichst eins zu eins
Abgeschrieben und copy pasted
Aufs Papier
Was der Lehrer an die Tafel geschrieben hat
Und das ist eigentlich total
Sinnlos
Du solltest ja halbwegs verstehen um was es da geht
Und da sind sowas
Da sind elektrische Tafel oder irgendwelche
Whiteboards oder Surface Hubs
Sind da wirklich cool
Weil da kannst du das was du gemacht hast
Danach einfach per E-Mail an alle schicken
Oder wenn einem E-Mail zu Boomer ist
Oder nicht Boomer genug
Dann auch per Fax
Oder bestimmt mal mit ganz viel anderem Kram
Aber Schule muss ich sagen
Ich war eh jemand der ich war so faul
In der Schule Leute
Es gibt glaub ich niemand
Der so fauler sein kann als ich
Oder fauler gewesen ist als ich in der Schule
Ich hab nichts gemacht
Ich hab gar nichts gemacht
Es hat trotzdem irgendwie funktioniert
Ernsthaft
Das ist richtig feifett
Das würde
Das würde ja sogar theoretisch funktionieren
Wenn man
Das Gehäuse irgendwie entfernt
Und nur das Display hat und das dann ansteuert
Das funktioniert ja so
Also es gibt ja wirklich diese Kombination
Neben einem alten LED
Ein altes LED Panel und ein Overhead Projekter
Und du kannst so eine Art Beamer draus machen
Aber das meinte die wahrscheinlich nicht
Deine Top 5 Games die du je gezockt hast
Oh da muss ich mir
Ein bisschen Gedanken drüber machen
Aber Half-Life ist auf jeden Fall dabei
Definitiv
Aber ansonsten müsste ich mir
Also Dark Edge of Camelot und Half-Life sind auf jeden Fall dabei
Bei den anderen Kandidaten
Müsste ich mir wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Gedanken machen
Und wahrscheinlich gibt es sogar viel viel mehr als
5 die ich gar nicht
Mit 5 wahrscheinlich gar nicht aus
Unsere Firma macht zurzeit
Fake Scam Nachrichten um die Mitarbeiter
Dafür zu sensibilisieren. Das ist eine gute Idee
Wisst ihr was die Firma macht
Wo ich arbeite
Die machen neuerdings
News Posts
Wo man denkt das muss
Fake sein aber es ist echt
Das ist auch mal weh das musst du auch erstmal schaffen
Doppel Chebat
Reverse Chebat
Hast du Erfahrungen mit
Funktionalen Programmiersprachen
Nicht wirklich großartige
Ne
Facebook haben wir uns schon drüber ausgelassen
Facebook existiert heute aber heute nicht mehr
In den Routern dieser Welt
Bis es wieder existiert
Dauert
Dauert ein bisschen
Falls sie die Routen wieder annoucen
Keine Ahnung vielleicht gehts wieder gehts wieder
Facebook wieder
Oh Big Brain Time
Für den Lehrer wahrscheinlich
Würdest du Overwatch
Wieder testen wenn das große Update kommt
Das ist ne gute Frage
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Ich glaube ich hab zu keinem Spiel
So eine
Liebe Hass
Beziehung wie
Overwatch
Das gebe ich mir nicht mehr
Ne
Die Sache ist die
Ich glaube auch nicht an Overwatch 2
Wenn man das mal so nennen kann
Also ich glaube das das in Entwicklung ist
Ich glaube nicht das Blizzard
Aber ich glaube nicht an den Erfolg
Oder das Auferstehen an das
Neue
Ja
Oder das
Rennen von Overwatch 2
Dass da irgendwie was rauskommt
Ich trau mich nicht
Neu ist E-Mode mal gucken was du rausgesucht hast
Ob
Brauchen wir nicht
Lohnt es sich diese Cisco
Welches welches
Cisco hat 85.387
Hab ich nachgeguckt
Zertifikate
Welches dieser Zertifikate meinst du
Kann ich den CCNA oder
Falls es ein CCNA ist ja dann lohnt sich das
Das ist wirklich nicht verkehrt
Da lernt man ein bisschen Netzwerkgrundlagen
Und man lernt ein bisschen Cisco
Slang
Cisco hat so den Hang dazu manche Sachen
Anders zu nennen oder umgedreht
Andere Hersteller nennen es anders
Ja zum Beispiel
Was ist ne Trunkport
Was ist ne
Hot Aggregation und sowas
Die Hersteller manchmal so ein bisschen
Und es ist nicht verkehrt
Also wenn es ein CCNA ist Twitch
Danke für den Zapp
Außerdem sagen
Cisco geschulte Leute
Nicht mehr Router sondern Router
Wie die coolen Leute
Das halt so machen
Aber wenn es ein CCNA
Findest schon dass sich das lohnt
So ein CCNA ist nicht verkehrt
Ich muss mir erstmal sagen welches Zertifikat das ist
Das unten links eine Half Life Reference
Nein
Das ist nen
Wow
Close and Update
Das ist ein besseres Terminal
Als das was in Windows eingebaut ist
Euch wurde ein Flip Chart
Gestellt für die Abschlusspräsentation
Das ist ja noch besser als ein Overhead Projektor
Genau
Ax
Ja deswegen waren unsere Corona Zahlen
So verspätet am Anfang
Und wahrscheinlich immer noch
Weil die ganzen Gesundheitsämter
Und Sachen was da so drum herum
Die haben per Fax kommuniziert
Und dann wurden Zahlen abgeschrieben
Und eingetippt, ausgedruckt und gefaxed
Und oh meine Güte ey
Da kommst du dir echt vor wie im letzten Jahrtausend
Ja das stimmt
Schaff nicht mal das Beginner Puzzle
Ja ich hab nicht so genau verstanden wie es funktioniert
Du musst was finden
Was auf alles matcht
Aber ich hab es nicht
Ich hab es nicht
Aber das ist mir jetzt echt
Zu
High IQ
Am Anfang von Corona haben die Lehrer
Angeboten uns die Aufgaben per Fax zu schicken
Alter Fax
Ich hab nicht mal mehr
Einen Fax
Ich könnte nicht mal einen Fax schicken
Und ich könnte nicht mal einen Fax bekommen
Wenn ich das wirklich bräuchte
Dann würde ich mir einen Online Fax Box machen
Also
Achso auf live Alex
Nein, mach ich aber
Sollte ich mal jemals eine VR Brille haben
Bisher hat sich das für mich für eine Sache
Nicht gelohnt zu kaufen
Und ich weiß wenn ich sag es hat sich nicht gelohnt
Kommt der Chat jetzt wieder an, Max dann guck doch
VR Porn
Aber ich finde für die also
Game lohnt sich eine VR Brille nicht
Wie gesagt habe ich nicht großartige Ahnung von
Also keine
Großartige Erfahrung
Geht nicht
Alter was ist für
Musik
Voll
Je besser
Welche
Stream 90% reduziert
Na ja gut es kommt ja bald der Nachfolger
Weißt du ob
3,4k ein gutes
Einstiegsgehalt ist
Also kommt erstens drauf an
12,13 oder 14 Monatsgehälter
Und dann natürlich
Auch in
Welchem
Gebiet beziehungsweise
In welchem Bundesland in welcher Stadt
Was du genau machst
Also sag mal 3400
Mit 14 Monatsgehältern
Was ist denn das
Das ist als Einstiegsgehalt
Okay
Ganz ganz gut
Mal 12 ist was
Ja das
Je nachdem was es ist
Ist das auch okay
Wo das ist was es ist
Aber
Sag mal so der große Bringer
Ist es da nicht
Aber kann man schon machen
Ja sehe ich auch so sehe ich auch so
Ich glaube ich habe den Chat bald durch
Oder
Gibt es eigentlich Leute die bei den IBM notes
Oh ja die gibt es also wir haben es mittlerweile
Abgeschafft aber wir hatten das auch ganz lange
Wir haben aber noch
Eine
Erlaubens- und
Abwesenheitsplanung die auf
Notes basiert
Wisst ihr was auch lustig war
Vor einem Jahr oder so als neuer
Kollege angefangen hat auf der Arbeit
Da mussten die
Damit sie eben einen Outlook
Account machen können
Mussten sie ihm erst einen
Notes Account anlegen
Um diesen Notes Account später anschließend
Auf Outlook zu migrieren
Da habe ich
Ich habe mich auch vom Glauben abgefallen
Das ist euer Ernst
Geht das nicht anders
Stimmt ich habe
Ein Fax eingebaut in meiner Fritzbox
Korrekt da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht
Ich könnte tatsächlich einen Fax bekommen
Ich könnte wirklich
Einen Fax empfangen fällt mir jetzt erst auf
Ihr habt recht
Reale E sind Fax vorm Verfassungsgericht
Okay Sekunde das geht kurz
Das gucken wir jetzt mal schnell
Das ist Dieter Balk
Bündnis der Generationen
In Hamburg
Hallo
Also
Leute die sagen
Dass ich hier schon Boomer bin
Das ist mein richtiger
Wobei
Also
Wenn man sich für das bessere Auskommen von
Jung und Alt einsetzt ist man zumindest im Gehirn
Nicht unbedingt als
Das Bündnis an der Bundestagswahl teilnehmen aber
Aha
Also hat die Partei schnell die Beschwerde geschrieben
Die akzeptiert das Gericht
Allerdings nur auf bestimmten Wegen
Per Email
Darf es nicht sein
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht an
Der Postweg ist so lang
Also müssen wir das per Fax senden
Wer hat einen Fax wir nicht
Ja das geht nicht anders
Wenn du in Deutschland rechtskonform
Das Ding da deinen Anspruch dann musst du das
Per Fax schicken klar
Das wundert mich
Ich meine es ärgert mich
Dass es immer noch so ist aber es wundert mich
Nicht wirklich
Okay also ab zum nächsten
Copyshop
Bei Prüfungsbeschwerde
Aufs Fax
Nummer eintippen
Warten
Ah das ist schöne
Diese schöne
Gequitsche beste
Also ich weiß nicht wer von euch
Noch 56k Modems oder
336 Modems verwendet hat
Also ich konnte damals
Anhand des Aufbaugeräusches
Ich weiß Grase Puma Story wieder
Anhand des Aufbaugeräusches ungefähr sagen
Mit welcher Geschwindigkeit das sind
Ich verstehe das ganze nicht
Warum nicht
Wir reden von Digitalisierung
Das ist richtig
Moment Moment das ist falsch
Wir reden von Digitalisierung
Also bis dahin ist es richtig
Bis dahin ist alles richtig
Da hört es auf
Und unser höchstes Gericht
Kann nur angefaxed werden
Aber nicht angemeld werden
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht
Tja hätten sie mal D-Mail
Nicht abgeschaltet oder
Die hätten das gemacht
Der Bericht sagt dazu
Das Fax ward die gesetzliche
Schriftform
Eine elektronische Übermittlung ist derzeit
Gesetzlich nicht vorgesehen
Eine Woche später
Eine analoge Übermittlung vom Gericht
Die Beschwerde wurde abgelehnt
Und weiter heißt es
Das ist uns auch schon vorab
Per Fax mitgefallen worden
Wir haben kein Faxgerät
Das kam wahrscheinlich in diesem Store raus
Ich weiß nicht welches Faxgerät
zu benutzt haben
Ein Verdacht keimt auf
Schnell nochmal zum Copyshop
Vielleicht ist das Fax ja
Aber das hat der Copyshop schon weggeschmissen
Es kann doch nicht sein
Dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht
An irgendeinen Copyshop schickt
Natürlich
Dazu sagt das Bundesverfassungsgericht
Eilentscheidungen
Werden zusätzlich per Fax
An die Beteiligten übersandt
Die Entscheidung wird von den Beteiligten
Angegebenen Faxnummern übermittelt
Da muss ich jetzt mal sagen
Ich weiß gar nicht ob man da den Bundesverfassungsgericht
Zu einem großartigen Vorwurf machen kann
Die wissen ja wahrscheinlich am besten was rechtlich geht
Und was nicht in Deutschland
Die Gesetze dafür sind wahrscheinlich einfach
Das Problem
Dass wir einfach nichts modernes haben
Und irgendwie
Den Ansprüchen genügt
Das Gericht betont
Mr. Nickname, danke für den Sub
Nicht vorgesehen
Ja, verfaxt
Sorry
Na ja gut, wundert mich jetzt
Wundert mich null
Ihr habt noch Nodes als Main-Mail-Zeugs
Oh mein Beileid
Mein Beileid
Nodes ist wirklich Paint-Champ
Wer es nicht kennt
Zeig euch das mal, zeig euch mal ein Bild von
Dann wisst ihr, dass ihr das nie verwenden wollt
Wunderbar, wunderbar
Alter, ja Nodes
Poggers
Das ist doch mal
Das ist doch mal was
Nee, das ist falsch
Oh hier, da ist es doch Commander
Chip erklärt uns Lotus Nodes
Ist das nicht geil hier
Oh
Oh, vom feinsten
Lotus Nodes
Von 2018
Ernsthaft, es gibt einen News-Artikel
Das ist nett, das ist ja echt der Wahnsinn
Irgendjemand hat sich 2018 noch
Den Artikel bei Chip verfasst
Für Nodes
Na ja
Nodes war immer noch besser als Outlook sagt
Einer im Chat
Da kann man sich drüber streiten
Das ist eh so Pesto-Colera
Das mit Nodes
Gängige Praxis, ja
Da bin ich aber auch ein bisschen vom Glauben abgefallen
Als ich das gehört habe
Einer und Dankeschön
Für 19 Monate Hyper-Subscription hier
Hyper-Subscriber
Jetzt hast du auch den goldenen
Keks mit Gangster-Halskette
Morgen direkt Windows 11 gönnen
Also erstens, ich kann es dir nochmal sagen
Also für alle, die es nicht gesehen haben, könntest du ein Video dazu angucken
Wo ich ein bisschen zu Windows 11 auslasse
Ihr müsst es wahrscheinlich nicht kaufen
Es gibt
Für die allermeisten Leute
Mir fällt jetzt gar keinen Fall ein, wo es nicht so ist
Wenn ihr ein Gerät habt
Dann könnt ihr die heutige Windows 10 kostenlos upgraden
Außer halt eure Hardware wird nicht unterstützt
Von Windows 11
Da gibt es zwar auch Tricks
Das zu machen
Aber dann riskiert ihr, dass es vielleicht bald keine Updates mehr gibt
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass das
Microsoft nicht machen wird
Weil Microsoft ist so hinterher, alles zu updaten
Und die nehmen ja sogar in Kauf, dass regelmäßig
Rechner kaputt gehen beim Update
Die werden nach Möglichkeit auch alles updaten
Weil das nicht eine ganz offizielle Installation ist
Supporte der Installation ist
Also ich gehe davon aus
Wir schaffen Kohleausstieg noch
Bevor wir Faxausstieg schaffen
Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt, was bei Facebook kaputt ist
Also anscheinend ist es so
Dass es Facebook im Internet nicht mehr gibt
Oder nicht mehr gab, ich weiß nicht
Wie geht es mir da
Also die Netze von Facebook
Existieren nicht mehr im Internet
Die werden nicht mehr
Announced
Dementsprechend kann auch keiner mehr Facebook
Off machen
Also sprich die IP-Adressen
Von Facebook sind nicht mehr erreichbar
Kann man mal machen
Ich habe auch kein Problem, wenn das so bleibt
Dadurch sieht es erstmal per ZIP ein PDF Fax
Doch, doch, gibt es alles
Es sieht ähnlich aus wie Outlook 2003
Das Schlimme ist ja das Outlook Express
Von Windows XP
Funktionaler und besser
Als Windows Mail von heute
Natürlich jetzt nicht mehr in der heutigen Zeit
Weil es viele moderne Sachen nicht unterstützt
Aber rein von den Funktionen her
Und was drinnen war, ist es immer noch besser
Leider, muss man echt sagen
Ich verstehe die Daseinsberechtigung von Windows Mail
Genau, Gmail im Browser oder Thunderbird
Danke für den Sub
Wen haben wir da
Oh, das weiß ich nicht, wie ich das aussprechen soll
Levodicom
Oder so
Danke für den Preischamp
Nice
Cool, dass du es gefunden hast
Aber ich kann euch jetzt nochmal sagen
Der Preischamp, den wird es nicht mehr lange geben
Und wisst ihr warum? Weil ich zu faul bin
Erstens, weil es Geld kostet
Das juckt mich aber nicht so großartig
Also das wird ja benutzt
Ich würde es online lassen
Aber ich habe keinen Bock
Die Crawler anzupassen
Zumal das ursprüngliche Projekt
Die den Crawler gebaut haben
Nicht so schnell sind mit deutschen Jobs
Das heißt, ich müsste da ziemlich viel von Hand machen
Habe ich keinen Bock drauf
Habt ihr mal deine Domain verkauft Langs?
Ach du bist das
Der mal Max FPS gekauft hat
Bist du das ja
Der ist mir dann für
50 Euro oder so
Oder 100 Euro oder 500 Euro
Ich weiß es gar nicht mal
Angeboten hat
Das ist auch wieder so was
Wir haben eine Domain weggecrabt
Und wir sind dann angeboten per Mail
Was?
Das könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen
Dass das Arbeitsapp noch Lotus Notes benutzt
Ja und die Fairy, danke für den Sub
Max, das hatten wir ja gerade schon
Also ich werde garantiert nicht upgraden
Auf Windows 11, sobald es rauskommt
Habe ich heute im Video auch schon gesagt
Äh, das wird auch nichts bringen
Cloudflare ist nix
Die kriegen viele DNS Anfragen
Wenn du die IPs wirst, dann geht nur die DNS
Die sind, also so wie ich das verstehe
So wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe
Ist, äh
Ne
Die IP, selbst wenn du die IP ausbringst
Kannst du dir die IP ausbringen
Und die IP ausbringen
Die IP, selbst wenn du die IP hast bringt nichts
Die Routen zu Facebook sind weg
Da bringt dir die IP auch nichts
Wie fixt man sowas?
Man fixt sowas gar nicht
Der Provider von Facebook
Muss die Routen wieder annoucen
Und dann dauert es kurz
Und dann können es alle wieder erreichen
Ich weiß nicht wer der Provider von Facebook ist
Oder wo Facebook läuft
Oder ob Facebook ihr eigener Provider ist
Keine Ahnung
Ich glaube gleich habe ich den Chat
Gleich habe ich aufgeholt
Ne, haben wir noch nicht aufgemacht
Das kenne ich gar nicht
Ich kenne die
Ich kenne das vom Dezix
Die haben ja auch so eine offizielle Seite
Oh
Ok
Ja gut, aber die Frage ist ja immer noch
Wem ist der Router
Oder die Router
Was ist die Mehrzahl von Routern
Die Routers
Alter die Mario Kart Musik gerade
Welche Service Provider gibt es eigentlich
Doch da gibt es einige
Und das ist auch die Frage an welcher Stelle
Willst du irgendwie was haben
Was deine Daten transportiert unterwegs
Oder willst du das
Da gibt es einige
Ein NOC ist ein
Network Operations Center
Das sind quasi die
Die sich um Netzwerke kümmern
Und wo manchmal, je nachdem
Auch der 24-7-Support
Noch irgendwie so mit angeflanscht ist
Yep NOC genau
Ach das ist cool, gucken wir uns das mal an
Warte mal
Replay
Was
Yes
Der Tab
1KS was bin ich denn jetzt hier
Sehend
Ah yes
Alles klar
Ach da sind die Verbindungen
Da sind die Verbindungen
Alle möglichen Netze, die es so gibt
Unten ist die Timeline
So genau check ich aber immer noch nicht
Was ich hier sehe
Was ich gerade sehend bin
Das sind PGP Announcements
Ja das dachte ich mir schon
Aber was davon ist jetzt
Das Facebook AS
Ach das ist
Ach das ist Verbindungen zu einem
Ah
Ok
Dann hat keiner mehr Verbindungen zu Facebook gerade
So dachte ich mir das
Gibt Schlimmeres
Facebook brauche ich keinen Mensch
In diesem Video ist erklärt
Ich wusste es
Guck mal ich muss es nicht mal aufmachen
Ich wusste es nicht mal aufmachen
Ich wusste dass jetzt Rick Astley kommt
Übrigens wisst ihr eigentlich dass
Gerickrolled werden mittlerweile doppelt schlimm ist
Erstens wirst du gerickrolled
Und zweitens kriegst du vielleicht noch
Einen Strike weil du Copyright
Geschützte Musik abspielst
Eigentlich ist
Gerickrolled werden heute richtig hart
Dudududu
Dududu
Ey ich hab den Chat ich hab es geschafft
So da können wir doch jetzt doch tatsächlich
Tatsächlich nochmal kurz in die Stack
Auf einer Umfrage gucken
Von 2021 also die haben im Mai
Die Umfrage gemacht aber die Ergebnisse sind
Noch nicht so lange raus
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich reingeguckt habe
Hast du gesehen Twitter
Das ist ja das was wir gerade auch schon festgestellt haben
Wer ist das
Chris Wiggins
Kenne ich
Facebook, Instagram, WhatsApp
Are all down
Ja warum auch immer
Das hab ich so auch noch nicht gesehen
Because they host their own DNS
Servers
Ach so
Also sprich
Die Server
Die dafür zuständig sind
Letztendlich Facebook aufzulösen
Sind nicht mehr
Erreichbar ob Facebook selbst noch
Erreichbar ist ist die Frage wahrscheinlich auch nicht
Ach was
Ja wie gesagt also
Ich erzähl heute einfach irgendwas
Und wenn im Chat was kommt umso besser
Also was ist das beste was du machen kannst
Wenn jemand auf der Arbeit sein Rechner ungesperrt
Stehen lässt
Gar nichts die Finger von weglassen
Ich würde das nicht ausnutzen
Ich weiß es gibt Leute die können sich nicht
Das verkneifen
Aber erstens der nächste könntest du sein
Und außerdem finde ich es nicht
Es gehört sich nicht
Den Leuten da noch was reinzuwirken
Gerade wenn sie es halt einmal vergessen haben
Also ich würde es nicht machen
Ich würde einfach die Finger von weglassen
Weil du kannst ihn sperren
Das könntest du machen
Ich würde
Ich würde echt nichts machen dran
Wo die Dinger stehen ich habe keine Ahnung
Wo Facebook gehostet ist
Facebook wird allerdings auch nicht
Alles an einer Location gehostet
Damit wahrscheinlich hat Facebook auch
Weltweit verschiedene Locations
Die dann irgendwie auch
Zumindest die Eingänge irgendwie bei Anycast
Ich weiß nicht ich kenne mich mit der Struktur
Von Facebook nicht aus
Interessiert mich auch null
Ich verwende Facebook nicht
Das Problem bei Facebook ist auch
Wie kommunizieren die jetzt im Team
Wenn ihr eigener Messenger nicht geht
Ganz ehrlich mich würde es wundern
Wenn Facebook ihren eigenen Messenger verwende
Apple verwendet keinen eigenen Messenger
Das kam doch letztens raus
Apple verwendet Apple nicht Teams
War da nicht irgendwas oder
Slack, Slack
Slack verwenden die
Ja genau Chat
Die haben nichts eigenes
Discord
Was schreibt Discord
Having a good time being online
Ja so ein bisschen
Schibaden darf man doch
Würde ich auch machen
Kann Facebook auch nicht line
Facebook ist so was
Niemand kann Facebook line
Machen die wirklich
Mein Beileid
Nö nicht dass ich wüsste
Apple hat in der Richtung nichts
Naja ob die jetzt Teams oder
Slack verwenden
Macht jetzt ja nicht wirklich was aus
Die verwenden auf jeden Fall nichts von sich
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Ein paar wenige Teams verwenden gibt
Einmessage
So jetzt kommen wir uns auch nochmal die
Overflow Umfrage an
Leute übrigens schön dass so viele Leute dabei sind
Ich weiß nicht
Wo ihr alle herkommt
Aber schön dass ihr da seid
Leider habt ihr euch heute wahrscheinlich den
Residenz lieberigsten Stream aller Zeiten
ausgesucht
Aber trotzdem nice dass ihr da seid
Gucken wir mal kurz in die Umfrage rein
Also was gibt es denn hier Schönes
Blablabla
Also mich interessiert eigentlich
Liebte Framework und sowas
Also TopCountries wer hat mitgemacht
Kokona hat mitgemacht
India
Old Dawn Old Dawn
Germany
Ist auch am Start
Kanada
Ok
Gibt es eigentlich
Moment ich muss mal kurz gucken LinkedIn
Gibt es mein Profil noch
Das ist Fake
Fake Peter Agile
Fake
Fake das ist nicht mein Profil
Das ist mein Profil
Das ist bestimmt ChainLore ja dachte ich mir schon
Weitere Mitglieder Peter Agile
Ja ist
In Berlin gibt es auch noch einen so so
Das ist mein Profil
Warum gibt es
Fake warum gibt es Fakes davon
Danke
Danke für den Sub
Ist Twitter nun überlastet
Das kann sein sowas kommt
Nö
Was wenn wirklich einer so heiß
Ich hab doch meine Zweifel
Das kann ich auch einschätzen als Cloud
Agile
Chief Engineer Officer
Also
Wann haben die Leute ihre erste
Zeile programmiert
In welchem Alter
Jünger als 5 Jahren
Alles klar was
Na gut die haben Lego
Lego Mindstorm
Wobei das machst du mit unter 5 nicht
Was programmiert man mit
Unter 5
Da fällt mir jetzt eigentlich
Nix zu ein
Zwischen 5 und 10
Das ergibt doch irgendwie Sinn
Aber nicht unter 5
Redstone
Redstone in Minecraft vielleicht
Aber unter 5 spielt auch noch keiner
Minecraft unter
Okay die meisten haben angefangen
Zu programmieren zwischen
Zwischen 5 und 17
Sagen wir mal
Die meisten waren zwischen 5 und 24
Ja gut das hätte ich mir auch so gedacht
Also ich hab hier angefangen
Zwischen 11 und 17
Ja
Wobei wir relativ früher schon
Zählen
Wobei wir hatten damals einen CS Plan
Und haben dafür eine eigene Webseite gemacht
Also das waren halt
Zeiten wo man in der Schule einen CS Plan
gemacht hat und sowas
Aber das muss ja, CS muss ja nach
1998 gewesen sein, Half Life kam 1998
raus
Und dann schon mindestens 14 gewesen sein
CS ist doch ab 18, Minecraft ab 18
Musste mir damals meine Mutter kaufen
Ich hab nämlich einen offiziellen CD Key
Gebraucht für Half Life
Weil wenn man online spielen wollte
Dann hat man einen offiziellen Key gebraucht
Jaja
Da musste ich meine Mutter dazu
Überreden, Half Life zu kaufen
Und das war dann natürlich die deutsche Version
Mit Roboter Soldaten, aber es gab ja
Damals schon Blood Patches
Und alles mögliche
Oh bist du alt, ja bin ich
Okay also, wo haben die meisten Leute
Gelernt zu programmieren?
From Online Resources
Videos, Blogs, Schule
Nee in der Schule habe ich nicht wirklich
Was großartig gelernt in der Richtung
Books
Also ich habe gelernt würde ich sagen
Aus einer Mischung aus
Online Resources
Books tatsächlich auch
Online Forum
Ja
Von Kollegen habe ich sicherlich auch das ein oder andere gelernt
So eine Kombination aus
Fast allem hier
Wie viele Jahre
Programmiert ihr schon?
Tja gut, wie gesagt
Ich würde mal sagen, so ich habe
Ich dürfte so mit 14 oder so in dem Dreh angefangen haben
Denke ich jetzt einfach mal
Muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer drüber nachdenken
Also bin ich schon, jetzt bin ich 37
Pass auf Big Brain
Ich bin, wir rechnen das jetzt
Einfach 23 Jahre
Das konnte ich jetzt natürlich nicht im Kopf rechnen, 23 Jahre
Ist schon ein bisschen was
Years Coding Professionally
Tja, das kann man schlecht sagen
Ich bin ja nicht hauptberuflicher
Entwickler
Ich habe damit zwar was zu tun
Und ich verbringe den Großteil der Zeit
Das Tages damit Code von anderen Leuten zu lesen
Aber zählt das auch
Sagen wir mal einfach
Seit wieviel Jahren bin ich schon in dem Gebiet
Also die Ausbildung zählen wir mal
Nicht mit
Und
Also das was ich jetzt mache
Das mache ich seit 2012
War auch schon 9 Jahre
So hier dazwischen
Max programmiert länger
Als viele Leute auf Twitch überhaupt auf der Welt sind
Da ist was dran
Ok, was haben wir hier sonst noch
Was?
Years of professional coding
Experience bei dir
Ah, ah, ok
Nee
Achso, also wenn du Senior
Senior
Executive
Executive, sprich mir das glaube ich aus
C-Suite
Suit
Was auch immer das alles sein soll
Alter
Das wollen die engineer manager
Das ist für uns egal, who cares
Developer roles
Developer full stack
Backend, frontend
Guck mal
Da wäre ich
In dem Fall
Das ist aber alles nicht so spannend
Wo kommen denn jetzt die frameworks und die sprachen
Educational
Blah, ja
Das juckt doch keinen
Age
Leute
Hier sieht man es offiziell, dass ich alt bin
Seht ihr das
Mit 37
Mit 37 falle ich da rein
Quasi meine Zeit
Ist um
Vorbei
Pippenhands
Hat es erledigt
Fast tot
Könnte man so sagen
Gender
Eine
Ein
Schwieriges Thema
Also was haben sie hier drinne
Woman non binary
Gender queer
Gender non
Non
Nonconforming
Man, woman
Prefer not to say
Non binary
Or in your own worlds
Das ist für alle
Die
Attackhelikopter sind
Tja aber
290 sind männlich
Jetzt gucken wir mal
Von professionellen Entwicklern
Sie damit ihr Geld verdienen
Ist noch mehr
Ok
Das ist schon viel
Also ich hätte gedacht
Es sind vielleicht
Also ich hab schon gedacht, dass es in diese Richtung geht
Aber ich hab
Ich dachte vielleicht haben wir Glück
Und kommen so ein 7-8%
Mädels, weil bei uns sind gerade
Was so Design
Und IOS Sachen angeht
Relativ viele Frauen
Bei den
Bei der Appentwicklung und sowas
Deswegen dachte ich vielleicht reißt das
Noch irgendwie raus
Sexual orientation
Who the fuck cares
Alter, wen interessiert's
Wer oder was das gerne mit wem oder was
Treibt
Der soll ordentlich programmieren, ist mir doch wurscht
Wer da was mit wem und auf was steht
Was ist das für eine Umfrage
Mich
Wann kommen denn endlich die Web Frameworks
Und was die ja wo benutzt
Jetzt ist
Die Frage ob du behindert bist
Gut bei C++ Entwicklern
Wird mich mal interessieren
Kann man die Frage einschränken
Kann man die Frage einschränken auf
Welche Sprache die Leute benutzen
Mental health
Das würde ich bei C++ Programmierern auch gerne fragen
Okay
Technology, jetzt kommt das interessante
Jetzt kommt das interessante
Most popular technologies
Also zeig her
Was haben wir denn da
JavaScript
Das wundert mich nicht
HTML, CSS
Wundert mich auch nicht
Weil die ersten Leute wieder sagen
Warum fragen die HTML, CSS
HTML ist doch gar keine richtige
Programmiersprache
Aber ich habe schon oft genug gesagt
Also wie es meiner Meinung nach aussieht
Ich habe kein Problem damit
Wenn ich den Azubi frage zum Beispiel
Hier Programmiertechnisch und der sagt
HTML habe ich schon was gemacht
Das lasse ich durchgehen
Und es geht ja auch um Technologien
Es geht ja auch hier Programmierscripting
Und Markup Languages
Ja
Das haben sie für die ganz
Über korrekten Leute das mit reingeschrieben
Wenn einer sagt er hat Bash gemacht
Bash ist ja auch eine vollständige Programmiersprache
Bash hat schleifen
Bash hat if
Abfragen
Bash hat sogar arrays
Auch wenn die sonntags eklig ist
Man kann sogar Multithreaded programmieren
Auch wenn man das nicht will
Also JavaScript ist ganz vorne
Das wundert mich nicht
Hier erinnert sich auch nicht so viel
Also JavaScript ist ganz vorne
Das wundert mich nicht
Was ich vor kurz einen Programmierlehrer gehört
Der sagt
Man sollte HTML jetzt erst lernen
Bevor man echt zu sparen wie Java
Da kann man sich sicherlich drüber streiten
Ich finde es nicht
Ich finde es gar nicht
Möge ich
leicht emotionally
konzentriert
澤
sings
introduced
slept
stir
sp
cheers
mostly
methane
V
Daily
diesen
я
л
so
Um
schwer, wobei man halt sagen muss ich habe oft genug erlebt und ich merke das ja bei
mir auch, es gibt Leute die ganz passabel programmieren können, aber überhaupt keinen
Bock haben auf HTML, CSS, ne, überstehen geblieben, ja, auch die Unterscheidung zwischen
Programming und Scripting, weiss ich nicht, im Prinzip sind es alles Programmiersprachen,
das lassen wir mal sagen, HTML und CSS vielleicht nicht, aber im Prinzip sind es alles Programmiersprachen,
das kannst du da heute alles gar nicht mal so gut voneinander abgrenzen, wenn du sagst,
das ist eine Ansammlung aus ja Schlüsselwörtern, gewissen, gewissen Sonntags mit Schlüsselwörtern
und Grammatik, wo man halt einen bestimmten Programmfluss abbilden kann, was der Computer
machen soll, ja, und dementsprechend sind das alles Programmiersprachen, so also zeigt
mal her, JavaScript wundert mich überhaupt nicht, das ist, dass das, JavaScript ist ja
nicht umsonst die beliebteste Programmiersprache auf GitHub und man muss auch wirklich sagen,
ich, ihr wisst, ich mache mich immer ganz gerne mal über JavaScript lustig und JavaScript
hat auch einige sehr merkwürdige Sachen, ich sag nur dieses Batman Beispiel, das haben
wir uns jetzt ja auch schon öfters angeguckt, was kommt da raus, am Ende kommt dann da,
da, da, Batman raus, aber nichtsdestotrotz, ich bin der Meinung, JavaScript hat sich die
letzten Jahre über doch ganz gut gemacht, die haben viele sinnvolle Features integriert,
angefangen von Async Await, was ja auch noch nicht so lange drin ist, seit wann ist Async
Await in JavaScript, 5 Jahre oder so, es ist jetzt noch gar nicht so lang, das ist schon
in Ordnung, was die Jungs bei JavaScript treiben, JavaScript ist ein schönes Beispiel für, wo
man sieht, wenn da Leute mit Verstand an der Programmiersprache arbeiten, JavaScript ist
ja auch so ein Standardisierungsgremium, so ein bisschen wie bei C++, da sieht man, wenn
da Leute mit Sinn und Verstand daran arbeiten, kann was Gutes rauskommen und das ist halt
so der krasse Kontrast, man muss sich die Entwickler von JavaScript angucken, wo auch
so ein Gremium dran sitzt und was Gutes macht und man guckt sich C++ an, wo auch ein Gremium
dran sitzt und sich vorher wahrscheinlich irgendwas spritzt vor der Sitzung, dass das
überhaupt funktioniert, so, HTML CSS ist als nächstes, das wundert mich auch nicht,
das geht ja alles ein bisschen an den Hand, das Python vorne, das wundert mich auch überhaupt
nicht, Python ist neben JavaScript mit die beliebteste Programmiersprache, die es aktuell
gibt, gerade was AI, Geschichten, Machine Learning und sowas angeht, ist voll im Trend
und auch im wissenschaftlichen Bereich ist Python einfach so das Nonplusultra aktuell,
so SQL, gut, Datenbanken brauchen sie alle, egal welche Programmiersprache, Java ist auch
nicht wirklich verwunderlich, die Chinesen stehen auf Java unglaublich, ich weiß nicht
genau warum, warum die China-Chinesen so auf Java stehen, wahrscheinlich hat es Microsoft
verkackt, damit sie scharf zu missionieren, aber viele Repos auf Chinesisch, wenn man
auf GitHub guckt sind Java, aber auch aus einem anderen Gesichtspunkt wundert es mich
nicht, viele Business Software ist in Java und auch im Enterprise Umfeld ist Java einfach
beliebt, Node.js ist auch am Start, da sieht man hier schonmal, dass es eigentlich eine,
dass es eigentlich hier eher so eine Technologie, Technologieumfrage ist, nicht unbedingt Programmiersprache,
weil JavaScript und Node.js ist ja im Prinzip, also JavaScript ist die Programmiersprache
von Node.js, also in der man das programmiert, Node.js selbst, ich glaube C++, aber ich glaube
das ist einfach, dass man es hier unterscheiden kann zwischen Browser und Backend, so was
haben wir als nächstes, TypeScript, das verwundert mich tatsächlich ein bisschen, dass das so
weit vorne ist, ich wusste, dass TypeScript sehr beliebt ist, aber dass es so weit vorne
ist, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, wirklich nicht, ich hätte schon gedacht, dass es hier
drin ist, aber nicht, dass es Top 10 ist, als nächstes haben wir C Sharp, guck mal, da
sind die Microsoft Sachen nebeneinander, Node ist C++, ja sag ich dir, ja C Sharp hat es
auch auf jeden Fall verdient, das hat die letzten Jahre einiges zugelegt, dadurch, dass
Microsoft die Sachen open sourced hat und das jetzt alles auf GitHub ist, Microsoft
hat ja nicht umsonst GitHub auch gekauft, das haben sie auf jeden Fall verdient, dass
sie Top 10 sind, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, okay und auf dem zehnten Platz, wenn
ich mich jetzt nicht verzählt habe, ist Bash, ja gut, ob das unter den, zu den beliebtesten
Technologien zählen muss, da kann man sich drüber streiten, aber es ist auf jeden Fall
ein sinnvoller Skill, weil gerade um alles zu verbinden, was man so hat, wenn man sich
vorstellt, man hat eine Anwendung, die in C Sharp das Backend ist und JavaScript das
Frontend, du brauchst trotzdem noch die ein oder anderen Scripts nebenbei, sei es irgendwie
ein Deployment Script oder irgendein Builds Script oder sonst was und da bietet sich Bash
halt an, meistens sind das dann auch bloß 20 Zeilen oder so, da bietet sich Bash einfach
an, also kann ich schon irgendwie erfüllen, danach kommt C++, ich bin ja froh und schockiert
zugleich, also ich bin froh, dass C++ nicht in den Top 10 ist, das ist schon mal gut,
aber dass C++ hier überhaupt drinne ist, lässt mich am Verstand der Leute wieder zweifeln,
so PHP, gut, ich sag immer, also hab ich jetzt auch schon oft gesagt, PHP ist besser als
sein Ruf, C++ ist wahrscheinlich wirklich nur wegen Unreal drinne, ja, habe ich mich
verzählt, ist C++ Platz 10, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10++ ist Top 10, nein, auch
noch Top 10, na meinetwegen, PHP ist besser als sein Ruf und ist immer noch in saumäßig
vielen Webseiten drinne, auch viele Shop-Systeme basieren auf PHP, ist Facebook nicht sogar
auch PHP, was war nochmal ein PHP? War Facebook nicht PHP? Oder bring ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Irgendwie eine ziemlich große Seite ist PHP und man denkt immer, was ist das PHP? Facebook
ist PHP, ja, oder war mal oder so, ach deswegen ist das heute auch nicht verfügbar oder was?
Nee, aber PHP ist tatsächlich besser als sein Ruf, mittlerweile, gerade wenn man sowas
wie Laravel oder sowas als Framework verwendet, ist das wirklich ganz nice und PHP hat halt
so eine lange History aus viel Paints-Champ. GitHub ist Rails, nee, ich glaube nicht mehr,
oder? Twitter war mal Rails, Twitter ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr Rails, doch GitHub könnte
immer noch Ruby und Rails sein, könnte, weiß ich nicht. War es mal? Twitter und GitHub waren
mal Rails. Twitch auch? Das wusste ich nicht. Twitter macht jetzt Java Zeugs, also JVM Sachen,
das weiß ich. So, also C, gut, das hat auf jeden Fall seine Daseinsberechtigung, wenn
ihr mich fragt, dürfte C durchaus noch ein bisschen weiter oben sein. C ist, wenn es nach
Minimalismus geht, finde ich die beste Sprache. C kann nix, aber es reicht, um alles zu machen
und es ist übersichtlich, auch wenn ich nix Großes in C machen möchte, ehrlich gesagt.
So, danach kommt PowerShell, das Bash für Arme, für Windows, wobei das ja so auch nicht
stimmt. PowerShell gibt es ja mittlerweile sogar für Linux. Wer auch immer das verwendet,
hat jemand von euch schon mal PowerShell unter Linux verwendet? Es geht, aber weiß ich nicht,
ob das jemand macht. Ja, leider, wirklich ernsthaft? Also installiert habe ich es auch schon mal,
ich weiß nur, ob das wirklich ging, aber, ja, okay, wo, hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Mit den ganzen Fehlerbehandlungen ist C eher unübersichtlich. Wieso, C hat keine Fehlerbehandlung?
Die Fehlerbehandlung in C ist aufpassen oder crash oder memory leak oder undefined behavior
oder so. C hat keine Fehlerbehandlung, C ist einfach grip. ReturnCode-1, genau. Gut, wenn
das als Fehlerbehandlung zählt, dann hat C Fehlerbehandlungen, aber das ist ja keine
Fehlerbehandlung. Fehlerbehandlungen wären beispielsweise so was wie explizit in die Sprache
eingebaute Return-Werte oder Exceptions oder sowas. PowerWay, danke für den Sub. Gut,
PowerShell, warum ist denn Go so weit unten? Also ehrlich gesagt hätte ich Go viel weiter
oben. Warum ist denn Go so weit unten? Also Go hätte ich ehrlich gesagt Top 5 vermutet
mittlerweile. Es gibt so unglaublich viele Projekte auf GitHub in Go und Go ist ja auch
keine schlechte Sprache. Es gibt so ein paar Sachen bei Go, die mir nicht gefallen. Syntaktisch,
ja, leider gibt es immer noch keine Generics, die dann irgendwann mal 2030 kommen. Generics
in Go kommen ja immer bald. Unused Imports geht mir auch teilweise echt auf den Sack.
In Go, dass es zig verschiedene Variablen-Deklarationen gibt. Dass Go beispielsweise sagt, hey, mach
doch einfach drei Schleifen ineinander, weil das einfacher ist als ein Wear, ein Filter
und Select. Aber ansonsten ist Go schon okay. Generics sollten im August kommen. Deswegen
sag ich ja, Go-Generics kommen immer bald. Genau, es ist halt keine gescheiten typisierten
dynamischen, also Custom Implemenzierungen, Diktionaries, Listen gibt in Go, dass du nicht
richtig adden, removing kannst von Listen, außer mit diesem komischen Append-Konstrukt,
dass du ob eine Diktionarium Key enthält, nur mit so einer komischen extra Syntax checken
kannst. Also Go hat einige Pains-Champ-Eigenschaften, hat aber auch viele gute Sachen. Deswegen
wundert es mich, dass es auf GitHub eine saumäßig beliebte Sprache ist. Ich meine, das ist
hinter PowerShell. Das musst du erst mal schaffen, hinter PowerShell zu kommen. So, direkt danach
kommt Kotlin. Das wundert mich nicht. Jeder, der wirklich was machen will, ernsthaft und
Spaß daran haben will, auf JVM-Basis, verwendet Kotlin anstatt Java. Meinetwegen vielleicht
Groovy oder so, wie man es früher, aber Kotlin. Also müsste ich was auf JVM-Basis machen,
würde ich auf Kotlin-Basis machen. Bist du auch neidisch auf die Facebook-SAE-Dudes?
Äh, warum? Ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, äh, auf Facebook, tja. Also mich juckt es überhaupt
nicht, ob die online sind oder nicht. Wenn es an mir geht, die können ruhig offline bleiben.
Wir haben uns das ja gerade schon angeguckt, woran es liegt. Objective-C, ich glaube, das
gibt es ja immer. Rust, guck mal, Rust ist sogar, oh, das schmerzt mich ein bisschen,
dass Ruby so weit unten ist, aber ich kann es verstehen. Rails ist in der Bedeutungslosigkeit
verschwunden, bis auf ein paar übrig gebliebenen Anwendungen. Und vieles ist halt dead beim
System. Hast gesehen, sag her. Hahaha, ernsthaft? Hahaha. Ja, das stimmt ja nicht. Das, also,
das ist ja ein Fehler in der Seite, dass der sagt, ist for sale. Die Seite guckt einfach
nur, ob es DNS-Einträge gibt und dann zeigt sie an, die ist for sale. Du kannst jetzt
nicht wirklich Facebook kaufen. Die DNS-Einträge sind weg, ja wunderbar. Ja, viele Start-ups
haben mit Rails angefangen. Aber so für neue Projekte, also, ich könnte wetten, wenn man
jetzt mal nach Rails-Entwicklern sucht, das ist ganz, ganz wenig. Vergleiche Rails-Entwickler,
die gesucht werden, jetzt mal mit Rails-Entwickler von vor zehn Jahren. Da sieht man, da sieht
man schon, dass sich das eigentlich nur abwärts bewegt hat. So. Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Oh, gleich ist Bettge. Bettgetime. So. Die Facebook-Leute kommen nicht mehr in die Räume
in ihrem LZ wegen IoT und Dings. Was? Wirklich? Ach, wisst ihr, was ich geil finde? Wir hatten
erst letzten Stream oder vorletzten Stream so die Diskussion so nach dem Motto, ja, dass
man, man kann ja Google und Facebook und so und die wissen ja schon, was sie machen und
ich habe lustigerweise genau in diesem Stream gesagt, Leute, man darf sich da nicht so sehr
hinreißen lassen, nur weil man nicht weiß, was die anderen für eine Kacke bauen, muss
man trotzdem von ausgehen, die bauen Kacke und auch wenn das Gras auf der anderen Seite
immer grüner aussieht, es kochen alle nur mit Wasser, egal ob Google, Facebook oder Amazon
und heute so ein Ding, ja. Max, du hast in deinem Windows 11-Video die schlimmsten Sachen
vergessen, was denn, was denn? Facebook-Employees can't enter the Headquarters because their
batches don't work. Tja, dann soll der Zuck sich mal hinstellen und einfach vor jedem die
Tür aufschließen und sie kommen nicht raus oder was? Geil, geil. Ja, wenn Shit, dann richtig
Shit und ich Shit hab. Lin MCMS, danke für den Sub. Vielleicht hat er auch beim Zuckern
vielleicht einen Entstecker gezogen, ja, kann auch sein. Die Taskleisten, die man nicht mehr
nach links und rechts machen kann, ja, das stimmt, wobei mich das persönlich nicht stört,
weil ich hab die nie unten, aber ja, wenn man die nicht links machen kann, verstehe
ich, dass es einige nervt, ja. Eigentlich ist links richtig guter Platz, weil gerade bei
16 zu 9 Monitoren hätte man da eigentlich Platz, egal, was willst du machen? Heute Abend
ist das noch lustig, warum kannst du nicht arbeiten, wenn Facebook down ist? Das stimmt
doch irgendwas nicht. Das ist gar nicht so unüblich, weil das erweckt den Eindruck,
als wäre das üblich, aber wenn es einen ordentlichen Disaster Recovery Plan gibt,
dann sollte auch unter anderem physischer Zugriff ist in den Raum nicht mehr möglich,
abgedeckt sein. Das finde ich, es klingt erst mal wahnsinnig abstrus, ja, aber ist es
gar nicht. Das heißt ja nicht, dass man das jetzt instant machen sollte. Aber das finde
ich gar nicht so schlecht, dass man eben auch diese Sachen mit beachtet, ja. Aber mir schmerzt
tatsächlich, dass Ruby so weit unten ist. Rust ist gut, Rust aufsteigen den Ast. Assembler
ist auf Force Swift, Alter, VBA, MonkaS. VBA, ich glaube es geht los. Alter, VBA. Dieses
wollte ich übrigens gar nicht, ich wollte eigentlich eher das hier ein, wo habe ich
das denn? Hier, das wollte ich eigentlich drücken. Also VBA muss ich, wie spricht man
das eigentlich aus? Mad Lab, Mad Lab. Ruby, Objective-C, Paul. Cobol. Aber Cobol ist auch
am Start, das darf natürlich nicht fehlen. IBM großen Rechner lässt grüßen. Warum hat
Assembler 5%? Wahrscheinlich irgendwelches Embedded Zeug oder so oder super high performance
von handoptimiertem Gramm. Crystal, Crystal ist eine Sprache, die passt, die passt zu
Mad Lab. Nee, Crystal ist eine Sprache, die macht die Ruby Syntax nach und ich weiß nicht,
warum man die verwendet, wer weiß ich da nicht drüber. Max, baue mal einen Half-Life 2 Mod
im Stream, ist nur C++. Ganz bestimmt, ja. Da bin ich genau der Richtige für. So, also
was das ist, Database ist, okay. MySQL ist vorne, wundert mich nicht. Postgres ist das
dahinter, wundert mich auch nicht. SQLite, wenn es nach mir geht, wäre SQLite als erstes.
SQLite ist die mit Abstand am meisten verwendete Datenbank bei mir. Und SQLite dürfte auch
die am meisten verwendete Datenbank der Welt sein, weil SQLite ist so ziemlich überall
drinnen. Sogar Origin von EA hat SQLite. Alle haben SQLite drin. So, MongoDB haben wir
am Start, also auch für die ganzen NoSQL Fans hier, Microsoft SQL Server. Ja gut, wer
Microsoft SQL verwendet, hat eh die Kontrolle über sein Leben verloren. So, dann Redis hinten
dran. Wundert mich eigentlich, dass das so weit, wobei so weit unten ist das gar nicht.
Redis ist mit Abstand, wirklich mit riesem Abstand, die beliebteste, so dieser beliebte,
ja kann man in-memory Datenbank sagen. Ich würde mal sagen, so in-memory Key-Value-Store
oder als was, was ist eigentlich die korrekte Bezeichnung von Redis? In-memory Data Structure
Store, alles klar. MariaDB ist am Start. Ich habe bis heute nicht den Unterschied zwischen
MariaDB und MySQL verstanden. In meinem Kopf ist das irgendwie das Gleiche, aber doch
nicht. Jede Android hat eine SQLite-Datenbank, ja. Also SQLite ist die verbreiteste Datenbank
der Welt. MariaDB ist ein Fork, ich blicke es nicht. Firebase am Start, gut, das ist
hier für unsere Cloud-Native-Fans. Elasticsearch, ja, dass das mit drin ist, verstehe ich,
ist auch das einzige dieser Art. Oracle, ja, die 12% sind mit Abstand die teuersten 12%
so hier drinnen. Also das Zeug kostet richtig Arsche. Dann haben wir DynamoDB, das habe
ich noch nie in freier Wildbahn gesehen. Alle anderen schon, DynamoDB noch nie. Cassandra
bin ich mir nicht sicher. IBM DB2 habe ich auch schon in freier Wildbahn gesehen. Leider.
Couchbase auch noch nicht. Gibt es einen Grund, um Oracle zu verwenden? Ja, damit die Stonks
Manager Support-Verträge abschließen können und sich einreden können. Wir haben Support-Verträge,
deswegen müssen wir uns nicht selbst darum kümmern. Warum sollte man Couchbase verwenden?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Es hat bestimmt seinen Vorteil gegenüber MongoDB in manchen Fällen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, kann ich dir nichts zu sagen, habe ich nicht verwendet. Cloud-Plattforms,
AWS ist ganz vorne gefolgt von Google und Azure, wundert mich. Ich, so nach meinem Empfinden,
aber das mag wahrscheinlich daran liegen, weil wir auf der Arbeit viel Azure machen. Nach
meinem Empfinden hätte ich gesagt, AWS ist vorne, ganz klar, saumäßig viel läuft auf
AWS. Ich hätte gesagt, dich dahinter eigentlich Azure, stimmt aber gar nicht. Google ein bisschen
weiter dahinter, stimmt aber gar nicht. Hätte ich so nicht eingeschätzt. Wobei das ja auch
nur ist, was die Leute hier verwenden. Das heißt ja nicht, was wirklich weltweit wie
verteilt ist. Übrigens, wenn ihr euch auch mal ein bisschen an Cloud rantasten wollt,
kurz Ausrufezeichen Hetzner in den Chat, da könnt ihr euch bei meinem Partner Hetzner
Cloud, kurz Ausrufezeichen, könnt ihr euch einen 20 Euro Startguthaben sichern, ich kann
immer richtig reden, einen 20 Euro Gutschein sichern mit Startguthaben, könnt ihr bis Ende
des Jahres einlösen, wenn ihr Neukunde seid und euch schon für 2-3 Monate kleinen Server
mieten und ein bisschen rumspielen. Richtig, Pog Earth. Digital Ocean ist am Start, passt
nicht so wirklich zu den anderen dabei, die 2. Oracle Cloud Infrastructure, wenn ich das
schon lese. Musst du morgen arbeiten, also raus, ja. Ich muss mich gleich betteln. Wir
gucken uns den Rest das nächste Mal an. Leute, wenn ihr mich noch ein bisschen schwätzen
hören wollt und mein neues Video mit euch geguckt habt, geht auf YouTube, dann könnt
ihr das Video angucken zu Windows 11. Morgen geht es los, 5. kommt das raus. Und ansonsten
sehen wir uns im nächsten Stream. Bettke, also bis denn. Macht es gut, kurz gucken ob
ich jemand hosten kann. Ob noch keiner da. Auch Sempervideos haben da in diesem Stream
nur ganz kurz, wir raiden jetzt Sempervideos, aber ich hoste Sempervideos. Also Leute, bis
dann, machts gut, see you.